لا تعطي الفرصة لمن يقصد أمتنا
وبهذه المناسبة نستذكر شهداءنا الأحباب.
ونستذكر مواقفهم بالرحمة والشكر
جعل أماكن السلطة علي
رب العالم الإلهي، يا رب لك
أن تكون شهيداً في طريقك فهذا من أجلك
أن نكسب حضوركم بالحسنات
هذه الأمة التي تريد أن تخرج، هذه الأمة محمد
دمتم واعيين
يا إلهي
أكون
لا ترموا نفطنا وتقسيم وطننا.
يا رب اكتب هذا الهجوم الدنيء في التاريخ.
نحن نسقط
شهداء تكبير لا يموتون، الوطن لا يمكن تقسيمه
الشهداء لا يموتون، الوطن لا يتجزأ، شهداء
لا يموت ولا ينقسم ولا بالطائرات
هل سبق لك أن رأيت جرحاً ينزف ويحترق
كبدي، سآخذ السوط لتهدئته
سوف آكله مرتين يا رجل، لا تمانع وتتأخر
لا أستطيع أن أقول
سوف أزيله، سوف أدوس، سوف أدوس
كمية
سأزيل الخرافات من تاريخنا
ليست القوة في وجه الفهم، بل المعرفة الفائقة
لحظة
هو